اعتمدت المحكمه في كولورادو في حيثيه
قرارها استبعاد الرئيس السابق من الترشح
في الولايه على الفصل الثالث من التعديل
الدستوري ال 14ب عر الذي تم التصديق عليه
عام
1868 ثلاث سنوات بعد انتهاء الحرب الاهليه
الامريكيه في محاوله لاستبعاد المسؤولين
السابقين في الولايات المنشقه من العوده
الى السلطه بتهمه التامر التمرض على
الدستور ويقول مناهض الرئيس السابق بانه
او ان تصرفاته ترقى الى التمرد على
الدستور خاصه يوم السادس من يناير
2021 حينما حرض وساهم في الهجوم على
الكونغرس وتدخل شخصيا في محاوله للتاثير
على مشرعين محليين وفيدرالية
الذين طعنوا في القضيه الى المحكمه العليا
الفيدراليه هنا في واشنطن بان دونالد
ترامب يواجه 91 تهمه فيدراليه واخرى في
ولايتي جورجيا ونيويورك لكن ايا من تلك
التهم تشير بايه طريقه الى موضوع التامر
او التمرد على الدستور وان ما يجري الان
هو محاوله مما يصفونها بالدوله العميقه او
حتى حكومه الرئيس بايدن واليسار
الديمقراطي باستبعاد المرشح الجمهوري
الاقوى حاليا من العوده الى البيت الابيض
لانهم شعروا بالعجز على الحاق الهزيمه به
في مراكز
الاقتراع